to send his christmas gifts by saint
patrick's day
my friend and procrastinator ted
florendo did you write those down
because you have to write those down
brian you know that write what down
write down all those dates just nonsense
i'll do it i'm all done i'll do it just
kidding
it hasn't got any for me we don't know
yet we'll have to wait and see
54 degrees our high for the day today 56
are normal so we were below average
today
after having a nice chilly chilly
weekend where we're only 49 degrees over
the weekend we're
still below average for the day today 41
overnight for the low now the reason why
we didn't drop to the 30s officially is
because we had a little wind with a
little wind low friction temperatures
don't drop as much
but now those winds have calmed down so
we will for sure
drop to the 30s throughout many of our
neighborhoods which we'll show you just
bit 49 centenny hills
46 in summerlin right now 49 also for
sky canyon
54 downtown in north las vegas 53 out in
ellis 54 green valley henderson europe
50 even
and rhodes ranch and mountains edge
southern highlands all
checking in right now at 52 degrees how
about outside the valley 53 for prompt
51 for sandy valley got a lot of viewers
there too laughlin right now
uh currently at 57 degrees clouds right
now over us that gave us that wonderful
sunset
where we took that picture and our tower
cabinets on our social media if you want
to check that out
but the snow showers that we're seeing
that developed up there
in the north part of the state
diminishing as it makes its way towards
us and that's what we've been seeing
lately here's the next system that we're
watching right now just curling out here
in the pacific
this will increase our winds shower
chances mainly in the mountains this
time by thursday
but the chances for the valley seem
pretty slim
but we are confident on those winds that
we're going to see as early as
thursday where gusts could get up to 30
to 35 a little windy
and a little windy and breezy left over
on friday at least in the morning hours
and then after that your weekend looking
good into next week
also as those winds really will be
peaking on thursday
overnight lows here you go we'll be
right near the freezing mark for
summerlin
for aliante the edges of town of course
will be the coldest okay 33 mountains
edge roads ranch
31 saint rose parkway also seven hills
32 out in downtown henderson and 34 out
in nellis
north las vegas and downtown should be
around 35
degrees to 36 degrees 22 up there in
lake canyon look at that pump at 28
and 29 up there for you in mesquite
those are your overnight lows that's how
cold it's going to get in the morning
hours 36 officially
mostly clear skies we're looking at
calmer winds and allow those
temperatures to drop big time
57 for tomorrow sunny and cool with
again light winds tomorrow before they
pick up
on thursday here's your extended
forecast windy thursday
also gusts on friday too your weekend
though looking good
sunshine temperatures warm up a little
and the first day
of winter is on monday at 203
in the morning that's your most accurate
forecast denise back over here
what no game of thrones reference i was
sitting with the six
you're thinking winter is coming